did you know that every lawyer has a
huge
swinging
hammer
this is not a metaphor john oliver
covered the dispute between jim the
texas hammer alder i'm jim adler the
texas hammer and mike the alabama hammer
slocum i'm mike slocum the alabama
hammer to recap jim alder says he's
spent more than 100 million dollars on
ads branding himself as the texas hammer
slogan he's been using since the 1990s
that texas hammer he sued mike slocum
the alabama hammer for copying his
commercials line by line i'm mike
slocombe
slogan also calls himself the dc hammer
for his dc area commercials both
advertisements feature the lawyers
battling an 18-wheeler holding
sledgehammers and speaking right into
the camera promising to beat insurance
companies at their own game
that's what i thought silicon says he's
stopped running that ad and also claims
that he only calls himself the alabama
and dc hammers and doesn't mess with
texas i'm mike slocum the alabama hammer
slocum did appear to copy that
18-wheeler commercial but also has other
weapons or tricks up his lawyer's sleeve
or suit sleeves i guess here's slocum
threatening to shoot insurance companies
yeah well here's a target we can all
agree on
so what is this dispute really about
well alder owns the federal trademark
registrations for the trademarks the
texas hammer its spanish translation el
martio tejano and the hammer sorry jim
adler a martial tejano so what does this
mean well a trademark is a word symbol
or phrase used to identify a particular
manufacturer or seller's products and
distinguish them from the products of
another or services of another nike and
adidas have different logos that's how
you can distinguish which brands of
shoes you're buying and where they came
from trademarks are generally considered
a form of intellectual property like
copyrights and patents however
these are all different concepts a
patent is a legal right to an invention
which is a product or process that
provides a new way of doing something or
solving a problem it usually has some
sort of utility value a patent entitles
the patent holder who is often the
inventor to the exclusive right to
replicate use or license or sell that
thing
copyright on the other hand protects
original works of creative authorship
fixed in a tangible medium copyright
attaches to things like songs books
articles movies and art that means that
authors have the exclusive rights to do
whatever they want to the things that
they make the expression that they make
including the right to sell or otherwise
profit from them but copyrights and
trademarks are very different trademarks
don't reward the trademark holder by
giving them the right to sell something
the person or business which holds a
trademark has the right to stop others
from using a similar or identical
trademark without their permission the
purpose of a trademark is to prevent
consumer confusion about the source of
the goods and services trademarks
prohibit any marks that have a
likelihood of confusion with an existing
one that means that a business cannot
use a symbol or brand name if it looks
or sounds similar or has a similar
meaning to the one that's already on the
books if it's already being used in
commerce especially if the products or
services are related so that's a crash
course in the difference between
copyrights trademarks and patents and
believe me it's way way more complicated
than that but this is the source of the
dispute between alder and slocum alder
says that slocum calls himself the texas
hammer in the texas area which creates
consumer confusion since alder has the
trademark to the phrase texas hammer and
to prove that someone infringed on your
trademark you have to show that it's
likely to cause consumer confusion about
the source of the products or services
alder says google searches for texas
hammer pull up a phone number that
automatically connects the searcher to
slocum's call center this is known as
click to call technology click to call
ads are a new addition to the search
engine advertising and these ads don't
necessarily link to a website but
instead trigger the user's device to
call a predetermined phone number alder
says that by purchasing these keywords
slocum is trading on the goodwill that
alder accumulated in the texas market
with his hundreds of millions of dollars
in advertising related to the texas
hammer mark and while slocum's nearly
identical commercial seems like a pretty
clear-cut case of copying the issue
there would be
potentially copyright infringement
because copyright applies to the
expression of the commercial the scenes
that are used the
lines of dialogue in that particular
commercial whereas trademark would be
the issue when it comes to the actual
marks themselves the use of hammer in
advertising whether it's the texas or
the alabama hammer or any other kinds of
hammers that come up in that particular
commercial and it gets even more
complicated when you're talking about
click to call advertising and
advertising on search engines and online
where a competitor buys the right to
advertise using a competitor's mark in a
keyword so for example if you say
anytime someone searches for the texas
hammer i want you to show my ads for
the alabama hammer uh
it's
a complicated issue that i won't go too
far into in this video but there is an
additional wrinkle to this case that
makes it much more fun because when
alder applied for his original hammer
trademarks he told the uspto the u.s
patent and trademark office that he
wouldn't be confused with lawyers in
other jurisdictions such as the kentucky
hammer that's because he needed to
establish the geographic scope of his
trademark protection just because you
have a trademark in one area doesn't
mean you can exclude everyone else from
using that mark in the entire country
now john oliver does a great job of
covering the controversy between slocum
and alder which is hilarious in its own
right but what oliver misses out on is
that this is just the tip of the hammer
iceberg there are far far more hammer
lawyers in the united states it's kind
of its own thing so let's talk about the
kentucky hammer i'm attorney darrell
ozitz the hammer that is daryl isaacs a
kentucky ohio and indiana lawyer who
bills himself as
the hammer like slocum and alder isaacs
is also an auto accident personal injury
lawyer who likes to fight with 18
wheelers so if you search for the hammer
lawyer google may display an ad for the
hammer law firm which is actually
isaac's neither alder or slocum so if
alder spent 100 million dollars on
advertisements you can imagine how much
money the kentucky hammer has spent on
his own super bowl commercials one of
those ads shows isaac in a spaceship
reenacting star wars which
raises all kinds of other intellectual
property issues but it's pretty funny
because when princess leia's spaceship
gets t-boned she knows just who to call
help me daryl isaacs you're my only hope
on my way you know for lawyers they are
skirting awfully close to very
established intellectual property
isaacs also wrote a dragon for his next
super bowl advertisement which was based
on game of thrones in fairness though
that is better cgi than you can find on
the cw and that advertisement is better
than the last episode of game of thrones
now in addition to calling himself the
hammer in the louisville and
indianapolis markets isaacs markets
himself as the heavy hitter but things
get even more complicated because would
you imagine that there might be more
than three hammer in lawyers in the usa
well of course there are because
georgia has jaime casino a man so
committed to his hammer persona he ran
several commercials during the super
bowl in his local market of savannah the
2014 version is a two minute long
commercial and features jaime wearing
black leather getting personal with the
hammer while a metallica cover band
plays in the background i mean just look
at that fire and here's jamie with a
cross around his neck absolutely messing
up some tvs in the 2018 super bowl ad is
he taking on insurance companies or
preparing to stake some vampires
who can say but we're not done yet
insurance companies are also the target
of the illinois hammer bradley dorkin my
name is bradley dworkin the illinois
hammer
now my favorite part of the illinois
hammer ad is its depiction of the
insurance company lawyer has this fat
slob with a messy desk and slovenly
clothing uh if you've ever had to
interact with insurance company lawyers
uh you'll get a kick out of that um
it's not exactly inaccurate
can you tell that i've had to sue a
number of insurance companies before
yeah come at me insurance company
lawyers now the illinois hammer's most
recent commercial is animated and
contains a truly memorable jingle seven
seven seven all sevens today the
illinois hammer is on the way honestly i
don't hate it but could there be yet
more hammers well of course there are
we're not nearly done yet because
lawyers are not that creative and the
hammer just sounds cool so lowell the
hammer stanley is a virginia personal
injury lawyer whose mantra is i am the
hammer they are the nails
now there is nothing subtle about this
particular hammer's messaging his basic
messages size matters and it says so
right on the screen lowell the hammer
stanley 459 cash
the new mexico hammers commercial is
tamed by comparison new mexico hammer
attorney brett parnell
i guess he just didn't feel like
investing in cgi zombies but you get the
point across you need a lawyer with a
big hammer and honestly there are
hundreds of other hammers out there
because there are a lot of lawyers who
have hammer as their last name so what
about lawyers with the surname hammer
like st louis base attorney mark hammer
well hammer is his actual surname so he
can't be enjoined from using
all the hammer puns he wants but mark
hammer's website doesn't use any of them
this could be because mark hammer isn't
down to ride the dragon or perhaps it's
because missouri's ethical limitations
on attorney advertisements are generally
more restrictive than the aba's
recommended rules of course men aren't
the only ones with big hammers amberly
hammer brings it down on doctors who
commit medical malpractice so how could
it be that there are so many hammer
lawyers in the united states well under
u.s trademark law there's no inherent
problem with several different lawyers
using the term the hammer in descriptive
geographical terms a trademark is all
about preventing consumer confusion so
if you are providing goods and services
to the entire united states then your
trademark would probably cover the
entire united states but lawyers are a
classic type of service provider that
are limited to certain geographical
locations passing the bar in one state
generally doesn't allow you to practice
in another state so often lawyers are
limited geographically by the states
where they are licensed to practice
and when a person applies for a
trademark with the u.s patent and
trademark office they obtain the rights
to the trademark either by being the
first person to use the mark in commerce
or being the first to register the mark
and that's what alder was claiming when
he registered the phrase the texas
hammer he claims that he beat others
including slocum to the punch by using
the mark first in a given geographical
area using the mark in commerce usually
means that you have sold a product or
service to the public with that mark
attached to it if you were the first to
do this you'll have priority to use that
mark in the geographic area where the
sales took place as well as other
geographic areas where your business
would be expected to expand or where the
reputation of your mark is established
so that's why alder's filings say that
his mark won't infringe on what isaacs
is doing in kentucky alder has no
intention of running commercials
branding himself as the kentucky hammer
call the hammer today
but at the same time it's hard to talk
about attorney advertisements without
talking about the regulation of those
advertisements because depending on what
state you're in lawyers aren't allowed
to say whatever they want to advertise
and solicit clients and jim the hammer
shapiro is probably the most infamous
hammer of all because his antics were so
notorious that new york actually created
new rules to stop him from making
obnoxious commercials i cannot rip out
the hearts of those who hurt you i
cannot hand you their severed heads
but i can hunt them down and settle the
score
shapiro's aggressive commercials ran in
the rochester new york and south florida
areas in addition to popping up in
winnipeg canada now new york eventually
suspended his license for running
misleading commercials and sending a
solicitation letter to a comatose
patient we conclude that any reasonable
attorney would know that a solicitation
letter sent to a hospitalized comatose
patient in the days immediately
following a collision between her
automobile and a train would reach the
patient and her family at a time when
they were unable to exercise reasonable
judgment in retaining an attorney
respondent who had actual knowledge of
the condition of the accident victim
will not be heard to argue that the
disciplinary rule required him to be a
quote mind and body reader in order to
determine whether his solicitation
letter could be sent lawyers get a
reputation for ambulance chasing but
actually most states actually have
explicit rules that say you cannot do
ambulance chasing and so it's not
surprising that shapiro got in trouble
in 2007 the new york state court system
adopted new disciplinary rules that were
inspired by the shapiro commercials the
rules prohibit nicknames such as the
hammer of course these rules would have
stopped alder slocum isaacs and stanley
from having a lot of fun with their
commercials so if you've ever wondered
why lawyers are no fun at cocktail
parties it's just because we're
ethically unable to have any fun
whatsoever but if you want to be the
head of your own dinner party i'd
recommend today's sponsor hellofresh
hellofresh is a great way to eat
delicious fresh food while still being
healthy in fact hellofresh has a variety
of calorie smart and carb smart recipes
as well as pescetarian and veggie
options now i'm a do-it-yourself person
and i have to say i was initially pretty
skeptical about hellofresh i'm a pretty
good cook so i didn't think that i
needed the help but i've actually loved
it even for an experienced cook
hellofresh delivers new ingredients and
recipes that i would never try on my own
hellofresh generally keeps everyone's
favorite meals and then rotates new ones
in all the time most recently i've
enjoyed my firecracker meatballs brown
sugar bourbon pork chops and crispy
parmesan chicken and i don't know about
you but i never would have attempted any
of those recipes on my own in fact i
usually increase the size of my hello
fresh serving so i can enjoy the
leftovers for lunch and snacks and
hellofresh isn't just about meals
hellofresh's marketplace features a
variety of add-ons like breakfast
desserts seasonal snacks again it's huge
time savings and of course everything
was delivered straight to my door so i
didn't even have to do any shopping the
produce actually gets to you faster than
a grocery store so it arrives at peak
freshness and flavor and it's also super
easy to save time hellofresh cuts out
meal planning and prep so the recipes
only take 20 to 30 minutes to cook
literally less time to cook than it
would normally take to do the shopping
itself and it's incredibly sustainable
since the ingredients are pre-portioned
there's less prep and less wasted food
the packaging is almost entirely made
from recyclable or already recycled
content and hellofresh's carbon
footprint is actually 25 lower than that
of meals made from store-bought
groceries so if you would like to try
hello fresh and i recommend that you at
least try it you can go to
hellofresh.com and use the code legal
eagle 16 for up to 16 free meals and
three surprise gifts yes you can
actually get 16 free meals that include
free shipping or you can just click on
the link that's on screen right now so
again for up to 16 free meals and three
surprise gifts go to hellofresh.com and
use the code legaleagle16 or just click
on the link below or the one that's on
screen right now plus clicking on this
link really helps out the channel and
while you're at it click on this
playlist over here with all my other
legal videos so click on this link or
i'll see you in court